HAOHSIANG LIAO: We conduct
the class entirely in Chinese
starting from day two,
after orientation.
So if they need
orientation, we clearly
tell students about
roles and expectations.
I would say there are a
few key components here
to make it happen.
The first one is we tell
students that our idea here
is that we're trying
to create Chinese
as an atmosphere as possible.
And if we were to refer to
English every few minutes,
it's going to be
impossible to accomplish.
So in order to do this, there
are a few key components.
One is classroom expressions.
So students, they
need to be familiar
with those instructions
you want them to do.
For example, you want
them to repeat after you,
or you want them to
answer questions.
So the classroom expressions
are very important.
Second thing is they
need to know what they
are expected to do in class.
So that is about your
weekly schedules--
that detail, everything you
want them to do in class.
So for example, you need
to tell students what they
need to prepare before class.
And in class you only
practice-- you only drill them
based on those materials.
So what they do in class
is what they've prepared.
And with the
classroom expressions,
they're pretty
easily guided by you
so that the whole interaction
can be in Chinese.
And, of course, we
do understand that,
because of the anxieties-- or
sometimes students cannot fully
understand what you say.
In that case, we always tell
students be a little bit
patient.
If you really have questions
you need to ask in English,
there are a couple
of things you can do.
You can do it the last
five minutes of class.
Or you can do it after class.
Or you can communicate with
your instructor via email.
But for the first 45
minutes, we really
want to create the
Chinese atmosphere
so that everybody
can feel they're
immersed in that culture.
So this is what
we're trying to do.
And I think after, I would say,
the two days or three days,
students-- as long as you
stick to the principle
and also be
accommodating sometimes,
they would know
this is expected.
And I would say after
three days they usually can
follow along very, very well.